[Musique]
il y a cinq ans susan wilson a eu la
chance de louis ce grand six et demi à
val-morin elie habite avec ses trois
enfants et paye 850 dollars par mois
il est situé au deuxième étage de cette
maison d'alluré champêtre et à 200
mètres de la plage municipale à jassans
baissé j'aime la nature la pêche
sauf que la famille devra partir le 1er
juillet la maison a été vendue et le
nouveau propriétaire l'habitera suzanne
qui a des problèmes de santé qui
l'empêchent de travailler reçoit l'aide
sociale
presque chaque jour elles patrouillent
la région de saint-jérôme à mont
tremblant charge des rages macheteau
valiant centraux charest pantois et demi
c'est 1200 pas mort pour chauffer un
toit et demi la pstwo j'appelais anneaux
un cat ennemis se juger j'ai trois
enfants et musées mais 5 et à 200 mhz
avaient fusé traitent leur surchauffe du
marché immobilier télétravailler
popularité de la région gentrification
les laurentides sont de moins en moins
accessibles aux résidents plus pauvres
travailleuse de rue depuis 9 ans sur le
territoire mélanie bolduc aide
actuellement une vingtaine de personnes
démunies
moi j'en vois des gens dans des chambres
d'hôtel à 900 dollars par mois ça nous
donne une bonne idée que les champs où
les appartements sont pas disponibles
pour vraiment pas la police lui avait
signalé ce matin là la présence d'une
tente dans ce boisé le long de la 117 à
sainte agathe
en plus des prix élevés des logements la
pandémie a incité bien des sans abri a
quitté montréal est de plus en plus
d'itinérants se retrouvent dans les
laurentides
mais ce n'est pas dans les habitudes
avance trompe faudrait plus
l'instabilité résidentiel reprendre le
terme de coaching et le jpy d'emploi je
vais aller coucher un jour les toucher
l'eau lorsque je vois ce que c'est de
l'itinérance vraiment peut réduire en
convoi les gens s'installent
on a vraiment pas de ressources pour
tout les accueillir malheureusement
beaucoup se retrouvent à sainte-agathe
là où il retrouve quelques services dont
l'hôpital pour la première fois la ville
a dû leur ouvrir un refuge permanent cet
hiver sept personnes peuvent dormir
chaque soir il est presque toujours
plein jean-pierre viens ici depuis un
mois j'ai couché dehors corps humain
labour à sainte-adèle thème annuel soit
un marché pauvre fait craquer chez
crypto les ministres et nancy ponton est
responsable du refuge selon elle une
centaine de ménages seront bientôt en
difficulté dans la région qui l'on voit
vraiment crise
je suis très inquiète pour des gens qui
vont se retrouver à la rue le 1er
juillet même s'ils prennent la décision
de trouver un loyer trop cher pour leurs
moyens même look bien trouve peau
au cours des prochaines semaines le
centre de santé et de services sociaux
des laurentides compte ouvrir un autre
refuge à mont-laurier vote alors penser
à trouver comme un peu dans les
sinistres des gymnases d'écoles pour
accueillir ou descente de des camps
d'été qui sont peut-être pas utiliser
cet été qu'on voit ce qui se passe sur
nos territoires et on n'est pas habitué
à ça c'est qu'on faisait à ce nouveau
phénomène là chez les élus locaux
on sent un certain malaise devant luthi
l'iran ce set y vas y en a 400 qui dès
qu'ils quittent rennais veulent marin il
y en a à mont tremblant aussi des
panneaux mandé saison nous entamons le
maire de seix lagarde et michèle il faut
les hérissons tout chez nous la pi 2 on
peut pas s'occuper de toute la
population parce que dans le fond il ya
des signes rask tu peux toujours issus
de ce1 de sainte agathe et des tissus de
tout un territoire à mort les mères sont
maintenant qu'ils doivent trouver des
solutions à long terme
ça prend de l'argent ça prend 10 c'est
d'être dette en arrière de nos
organismes
le poilie supporter offrir des locaux
québec sera sollicité pour plus d'argent
entre autres pour la construction de
logements sociaux
ça va être le nerf de la guerre quand
vous mettez sur l'état de conservation
j'arrête pas d'en parler on a des listes
d'attentes 1 à 2 ans des logements
sociaux et à neuf ans dans toutes les
villes suzanne affirme être sur une
liste d'attentes depuis trois ans pour
une place en hlm
alors elle cherche et cherche encore
pour ne pas se retrouver à la rue
je repense à aller avec mes enfants
moussa d'ange pour mai afin là dedans
j'ai trois ans femme de joueur pas
qu'ils vivent avec le 1er juillet qui
s'en vient son inquiétude augmente
chaque jour ici j'en sais pas c'est que
l'outil radio canada val morin